oh well currently inside gatwick airport
there are long queues at bag drop and
check in but it is half term and they do
appear to be moving the main issue in uh
there in the north terminal at least at
the moment is the flight cancellations
by tui so there are a lot of upset
passengers they've cancelled a small
number of flights um across the country
just a couple from gatwick here uh one
of them was to verona so there's quite a
few people in there and i think what
strikes me about this is that they they
all have their own individual stories so
there was a a woman who was trying to
get to see her grandson that she's never
met before uh there was a woman who's
missed her own wedding as a result of
this this flight being delayed and
delayed and delayed and possibly uh even
cancelled and then there was a nurse who
got in touch she was close to tears
saying this was her first big break
since before the pandemic so i feel that
these these holidays mean more than ever
post pandemic we've also been speaking
to paula blake who was supposed to go to
lake garda for her 50th birthday this is
what she had to say
what they've said to us now is that
we're definitely flying
at quarter to one in the morning
and they can't find us any hotels
they've said it's covered they've said
there's a conference on they've said um
they don't know so none of them seem to
know on the floor level what's happening
but we're getting kind of hints that
they do know more um
up above if you like because a minute
ago our flight was on the screen saying
10 to 5 tomorrow morning
which is actually half an hour under the
24 hour limit where they have to give
you a refund
now tui have apologized in a statement
they've said that the hard term holidays
are always an incredibly busy period
with many customers looking to get away
unfortunately due to various operational
and supply chain issues a small number
of flights have been delayed or
cancelled we'd like to reassure
customers that we're doing everything we
can to minimize delays
now i think there's a lot of anger
as well as with the easyjet
customers that this has all been such
late notice the question that they're
all all asking is why this couldn't have
been foreseen uh late notice and they're
also claiming particularly the easyjet
passengers that there haven't been any
viable solutions put forward by the
airline to try to save their family
holidays british airways have also
released a statement they talk about uh
these being a very challenging uh being
a very challenging period for the
industry and they also talk about how
they're undergoing their biggest
recruitment drive in history so reading
between the lines there overall
the the travel industry
is potentially struggling to cope with
the sheer amount of demand for flights
post pandemic and i think what the
question really is
what will the summer months being bring
it doesn't bode well does it